Germany's Ursula funder line has
addressed the European Parliament in
Strasbourg as she winds up her bid to
become the first woman president of the
European Commission it was her last
chance to make her case EU lawmakers
still on the fence about her nomination
Thunder lion needs to secure a majority
in a secret confirmation ballot being
held later today in her speech she
sought to allay concerns of lawmakers
who have criticized her for being overly
vague laying out a number of ambitious
policy points on topics including trade
gender equality migration and brexit
there was also a big appeal to the green
lobby with funder Lyon pledging a green
deal for Europe in her first 100 days
achieving her goals on climate change
she said would require a new sense of
unity we must first rediscover our unity
if we are united on the inside
nobody will divide us from the outside
if we close the gaps between us we can
turn tomorrow's challenges in tomorrow's
opportunities honourable members our
most pressing challenge is keeping our
planet healthy this is the greatest
responsibility and opportunity of our
times
let's bring in now DWS chief political
correspondent Melinda crane who joins us
here in the studio and our Brussels
bureau chief max Hoffman is standing by
at the European Parliament in Strasbourg
max I'll turn to you first because her
nomination has been controversial
especially among parliament deputies
this was really her last chance to
convinced them do you think that she did
because I mean we just heard from the
Greens and they say we're still not back
in her it seems though that the stars
are aligning in favor of was Olaf on the
line we talked to a couple of MEP s here
in the meantime and even the Greens that
were the first to say we are not going
to vote for lose enough on the line
after meeting her last week said this
was a pretty good speech we talked to
one representative of the Belgian Greens
for example
and I asked her on a scale of one to ten
ten being the best score what do you
give Oz Olaf on the line for that
speeches she said a seven or eight so
she really managed to cater towards the
greens whether this really changes their
overall decision not to vote for her
that's something they're gonna have to
hash out this afternoon when the
political groups meet but if even the
greens are a little shaky now on their
position it means that she probably
swayed some votes among the Social
Democrats it probably also means that
the EPP is even more firmly behind her
than before EP P being the Conservatives
her own party
so most people we talked to here seem to
think that she's going to make it okay
and no matter which way you cut it
though at the end of the day this is a
historic vote this is the first time
that a woman has gone up for a president
of the European Commission she addressed
that issue let's have a listen and then
I'll get your reaction thereafter I will
ensure full gender equality in my
college of commissioners
if member states do not propose enough
female commissioners I will not hesitate
to ask for new names since 1958 there
have been 183 commissioners only 35 were
women that is less less than 20%
we represent half of our population we
want our fair share quoting some
embarrassing statistics there Melinda is
this gender card working for her or
against her you think we'll know this
evening but I think it could very well
work for her because the party groups
that she most needs to convince she has
the Conservatives behind her anyway and
they like by the way the fact that she
she's a woman but she's also a mother of
seven children that that plays well with
conservatives so the other party groups
that she needs to convince our Social
Democrats and also members of the
Liberal Party that's the market friendly
party and I think on both counts there
are a lot of MEP s members of European
Parliament who do support stronger roles
for women so I think she is possibly
likely to ratchet up a little bit in
their estimation on the basis of that
really quite clear statement right at
the outset of her speech max tell us
because one of the big issues has also
been the fact that she is not the
so-called lead candidate the the Schmitz
encana dot just walk us through the
controversy there and how big of a
barrier this could be to her election
well as you know the lead candidate
principle was invented five years ago
and the idea behind it was that only one
of those lead candidates of the
different political groups here in their
European Parliament would be eligible to
become Commission president afterwards
this worked quite well five years ago
because the two biggest groups back then
the Social Democrats and the
Conservatives were in the same page and
said okay the European People's Party
the conservative had the largest share
of their vote and jean-claude Juncker
was their lead candidate and therefore
he will be lected among parliamentarians
we have a majority and this will work so
the leaders really didn't have another
choice but to put acknowledged this and
say ok we're on board with it if they
didn't want to risk a huge institutional
fight this time the Parliament did not
have a majority behind one of those
leaked candidates neither behind the
lead candidate of the Conservatives who
was monthly vibha neither behind
northern candidate of the Social
Democrats who was fenced Timmerman's and
that's why leaders took over they took
control of the process and now the
European Parliament is complaining about
what laughs underline because she was
not on the campaign trail because she
was not one of the visually candidates
and because effectively it takes away
some of the power that the European
Parliament fought for and Ashley got
five years ago Melinda how was her
candidacy playing back at home in
Germany mixed at least heretofore we
don't know about the response that
German citizens will have had to hearing
that I must say unusually strong speech
coming from ursula fund ella and she's
not known as a fiery speaker but there
was quite a bit of emotional pathos at
the end of that speech so last week a
survey showed that only about one in
three Germans felt that she would make a
good president of the European
Commission that depended a bit on party
affiliation those who were affiliated I
would either with the Conservative Party
or the free market oriented FDP Liberal
Party they a slight majority said they
did think she'd make a good Commission
president but on the whole not a lot of
resounding support that's partly because
she's had a tough job here as defense
minister instituted reforms that haven't
yet
played out there has been some criticism
of her leadership and in some ways her
image here at home is less bright than
it is in many other European countries
okay
max how will this vote now play out for
the rest of the day and do European
leaders have another surprise candidate
perhaps up their sleeves if Parliament
votes are Silla founder lying down right
now she's still being quizzed in the
plenary room of the European Parliament
here this will go on until approximately
twelve o'clock local time so another
hour or so because many of the
parliamentarians still have questions
there's only so many things you can talk
about in about 40 minutes speech so
there'll be more specific questions
she's being grilled but the the big
politician the top shots the political
group leaders have already asked their
questions then in the afternoon the
different political groups will meet to
discuss how they're going to act it
doesn't necessarily mean that all the
members of those political groups will
follow the recommendation made by the
group take the social democrats for
example they will most likely recommend
voting for azul upon the lion but the
German delegation of that group the SPD
was very was very adamant about not
voting for her by the way something that
raised some eyebrows around here also
among Social Democrats from other
European countries and then this evening
at 6 o'clock we have the secret ballot
we have the boat it'll take a while to
count all those votes and we do expect
an official result by 7:30 we do expect
her to win maybe by a small margin but
you can't be sure because it's a secret
ballot and if she loses we're back to
square one and the leaders will have to
suggest someone else over the summer
okay so a very jam-packed day today the
stakes are high certainly a historic day
for the European Union max Holtzman in
Brussels Melinda Crain here in the
studio thank you so much to both of you